guys sometimes if i'm having a
particularly stressful day or possibly
i've got some
neck or back pain or i'm struggling to
sleep
i might put a couple of drops of feels
cbd oil under my tongue
a lot of people who are new to cbd don't
know how much to take how are they
supposed to do it
feels has a hotline to help guide your
personal experience
and find your perfect dose nice feels is
a premium cbd that will help clear your
head
and feel your best it's hassle-free and
delivered directly to your door it also
has no hangover and there's no addictive
qualities to it
so start feeling better with feels
become a member today by going to
feels.com
onion and you'll get 50 off your first
order with free shipping that's
f e a l s dot com slash onion to become
a member
and get fifty percent automatically
taken off your first order
with free shipping that's amazing fifty
percent off your first order at
feels.com
slash onion
harmonize with me and hold me tightly
through the night
you're shining bright i'm your boy's the
baby you're my pearl
we're back here we are like batman
dinner dinner batman i used to love that
show when i was a kid
wow what's going on nothing much really
yeah
well i will say this right very quickly
i drove down to your house
again this weekend to watch more grown
men and women
fighting and when i was about five
minutes away from your house
at the traffic light i thought i've
known billy for 12 i've known billion
alley for 20 years now
and as i get closer and closer to their
house i get more and more excited
i love that yeah and today you came over
to my house to do a little bit of
business
and i was i had a slightly busy frazzled
this morning with talking to
agents and a couple of things going on
in my house that was a little bit
irksome and you showed up i mean in
three or four minutes
i was back in a great mood that is a
sign of a great friendship i love that
dom
and we're always excited to have you the
house because because you settle in
like an like an old dog yeah
you're with your little dog yeah you
just you get onto your seat
and you just settle in it's funny right
i've got my own seat yeah i have my own
little thing
with your dog that no one else really
does i call him bobert
you guys don't seem to call him bobert
we have our own little vibe yeah
i tend to go around the corner and grab
my favorite bag of crisps it's brilliant
lovely and then we just we just
basically settle in
and you were very kind because you
bought his pizza
i tell you what that was yummy pizza
right one of
one of the greatest uh reviewed pizzas
in
california is that right i don't know i
heard it on the news someone was saying
it was good it's called vetoes
now they're not they're not doing
anything for the show no they're not
paying us to say they
they make good pizza but it was it was
scrumptious it was absolutely lovely
pizza
do you know what it made it better well
that stuff
oh jardinera we should use that in a
show sometime for the
for the feed the world not to feed the
world no you don't
want to eat the word it's like a an oily
pickley
uh hot spicy
relishing saucy thing
we'll do it and eat the world we'll do
it at some point yeah hey let's do a
little uh
league of legends update
maybe someone from riot because they
seem to love us right now because
they're talking about league of legends
so much
maybe someone from riot can send us a
little graphic
league of legends update
where we at on a scale of fruit yeah
strawberry seeds being nothing and
watermelon being high success where are
we at with a larger play in league of
legends because there has been an update
hasn't there
there has been an update but i i'd still
not
to me dom it's not feeling incredibly
positive well he was
he was silent for about three weeks
nothing
and then recently he sent us both a
voice note saying guys i'm sorry
i've been busy i have heard on the
podcast that you keep wanting me to play
i've downloaded it i've yet to play it
and then who popped his little head
above the parapet
but sean asked him no less who said i'll
play
i'll play sean astin samwise gamji
himself said that he'll join our league
of legends can you imagine him running
into battle with pots and pans and stuff
like that he'd be brilliant
so right now i'm saying that elijah is
sitting around the tangerine
yeah i think tangerine's a good one but
sean ashton
is like a nice rape melon i was gonna
say pomegranate for sean
este and i'm not sure if he's i mean
that's your personal choice if he's
melon because i mean where'd you go from
melon all you go there is watermelon
that means he's playing
so you really think that he's
melon-sized not a big melon
okay tiny little melon like a tiny garla
yeah yeah something like that i love it
i i love pomegranate i love a
pomegranate too
so tasty hard to get the stuff out so
difficult
did you know here's a great tip with uh
pomegranate supposedly you cut it in
half right
try and invert it as best you can and
take a ladle
yeah put it over a bowl and smash the
back of it
with the back of the label thrash it
basically
and the uh seeds magically fall out
no well supposedly that's what the
internet
a says have to be stainless steel
i think stainless steel is probably
helpful i'll try that when i go home
my father my wonderful father hello dad
if you're watching because he has been
watching
um and listening he used to in a very
kind of
lovely uh kind of
i don't know like a very precious sweet
fatherly way
yeah when we were kids of a friday night
every so often
he would come home with a pomegranate
for the kids and i remember
as i said my jokes that were in the fire
and looking at my brother and i would
eat it with a pin
you would eat a pomegranate with a yeah
you take the pips out with a pin
but my dad made it a big deal it's like
look this when we he used to say to us
when he was a kid there were no
pomegranates no one even knew what a
pomegranate was so the glamour of like a
pomegranate or a pineapple
so instead of getting a bag of crisps or
a bag of sweets
he'd bring home a pomegranate and it was
and a pen great treat and i love how
special my dad made it you know what i
mean he was like this
is an incredible fruit and you will love
it and we did love it i love fruit
i'm still looking forward to the day but
i can sit with your father and watch
a nice movie or a gamer football and and
just enjoy together
a ton of condensed milk i'll set that up
for you talking to football
this coming friday your country scotland
play my country england in the euros so
by the time this comes out which will be
next week we've already fallen out
we one of us will not be talking to the
other one
yeah yeah it's a shame that scotland
lost their first game because i want
scotland and england to go through
so that we're all in the knockout stages
but there's a strong chance that they
might miss out
yeah that you seem quite sure well if
england beat them they will miss out but
if there's one thing scotland always do
they always put no wait a minute we
always lose and
right you could be right absolutely
anyway oh it's so exciting to have
scotland done something it is it's very
exciting to have them in a minute
it's lovely i think we've got a listener
stroke
viewer on the line should we bring that
lovely person in
let's listen to a listener well hello
mariah
hiya mariah how's it going
it's fantastic um i'm so honored to be
on here with you guys you guys are like
my heroes oh that's lovely very sweet of
you to say
uh and just before we started um
rolling the whole thing you introduced
us to your dog toby is he still around
yeah are you still here can we say hello
because people always want to see
people's dogs it's a massive thing with
these zoom chests
what's here it comes hi toby how old's
toby hey toby how are you toby
oh handsome look at that face
how old is toby and what's his what's
his vibe what's he into
uh he's uh eight years old he's a boxer
um he's very playful but um
also pretty chill i like him he looks
like a nice one
i love it where are you just now where
are you in the world
um i'm in atlanta georgia oh yeah
anna georgia i did a movie there the
year before last year oh he just did his
tv show there just a few months ago i i
had a lovely time there i went on quite
a few walks there's a lot of sort of
nature walks and uh you know i did a
terrible mistake tom
did you [ __ ] your drawers in a park no i
didn't oh cause that is a terrible
mistake i i went on a couple of walks
and they told me how long they were
going to be like three miles
and there were it was a circle and then
the next one i went to was like two and
a half miles
and it was a circle and then i went to
another one that said five miles
and i thought i'll do five miles today
five miles straight i went
i didn't have a wallet to get like a
taxi home or anything
i had to do five miles back again what
so in the same
day that you did two miles and three
miles no a different day
okay that'd have been too much for me
still a lot though yeah it's a lot but i
loved it it's a great place i love it
so hey mariah so tell us about your
journey
with lord of the rings in your life
did you did you read the books did you
watch the movies with your family did
you watch it with your friends what what
happened with you
oh both um lord of the rings has been a
huge part of
my childhood and my life it's like my
primary
fandom um one of my cousins and i we
actually used to pretend to be
mary and pippen um her name
was mary like m-a-r-y so she wanted to
be
pippin so she had a different name so i
got to be
mary uh nice um
yeah i get the mary thing a lot read
them and
listen to the audiobooks all the time oh
that's cool now do you think because i
get this quite a lot in the united
states people say
you know i really liked you playing mary
m-a-r-y do you think it's because the
when the english cast are saying the
word merry
to an american ear it sounds like mary
is that right i think it kind of does
like oh i hadn't really thought about it
until you brought it up on an earlier
episode and i was like whoa that is
really true
yeah and all right i think it's the same
though sound in america isn't it the
name
mary and like merry christmas
is the same sound let's just let's just
make sure that's true
mariah could you say to me merry
christmas
merry christmas and then say the name of
his character and lord the rings
mary brandybox yeah it's the same it's
the same sound
no wonder it's confusing in america i
was joking never thought of that
i was just thinking then though what and
i bet you'll struggle with this
can you name an actress with the name
mary
um m-a-r-y there's not a lot of time
yeah well there's one yeah give us
another one
right
mary elizabeth winstead would marry
kate and ashley there you go that will
do it yeah hurricane
ashley so there's actually quite a few
they're confusing those two because i'm
always trying to work out are they two
people or one
they're both too and they're both called
mary kate and ashley
no it's mary kate and ashley right
my mother was called mary oh there you
go there you go she wasn't an actress
well mariah did you did you come uh
bearing questions or did you come
bearing
possibly queries okay
so um first one say
a grizzly bear and a great white shark
could fight as if
they were in their natural habitats who
would win
now can i just get a little bit of
clarification from you mariah
on that question are you saying
two different fights a shark in the
ocean with a bear
and then a shark on the land with a bear
or are you saying what one fight
it's just one fight where they can both
just like be
in their best natural right yeah
i would say i would need to give that to
the great white
because he would come at such a
tremendous
force at the grizzly bear
that i think the grizzly bear would be
caught unaware
so i think an unaware bear i know where
bear
the fate would not be fair
but would you care i wouldn't care
because it would be
so rare would you stare
at the bear who was unaware
i mean it wouldn't it wouldn't be fair
no it wouldn't be fair
um so it'd have to go to the great white
for me
let me share okay i i agree with bills i
think
a great white would essentially
attack the bear with such force that it
would shock it
take a massive bite out of it gain some
distance
and then the bear would succumb to that
bite
obviously on land a shark's going to
struggle
for mobility but if they're in if the
shark's in a
in a strange kind of surreal aquatic
space
but this is mariah's point this is the
fantasy element of what you said
yeah i think ultimately because they
could also sharks can also
endure a huge amount of injury and
damage without
dying you've seen sharks with massive
bites out of them
just carrying on sharks also can't get
cancer and sharks do not get uh
because they don't smoke yeah good point
now
i'm gonna get a little controversial
here mariah get get in with this quit
this um thought with me here and you as
well done
i was listening to a podcast this
morning on the drive up
and they were talking about movies and
then i
a thought came to me and go with me here
dom
all right jaws is an amazing movie
i think we'll all agree can you agree
with that mariah
joyce great fantastic great film right
but it has made so many people
afraid of the ocean yeah afraid of
swimming and afraid of sharks
is it worthwhile having a movie that
great
if it causes so much fear and anxiety
i mean i i don't think that's that much
of a controversial
uh thought in fact steven spielberg has
spoken out over the years
saying that he loves the film but he has
his regrets
over what it did to the shark because
it really vilified the shark and that
was not what he wanted to happen well
that's nice to hear because i thought i
just had that as the i thought i was the
first person who'd ever thought that
this morning
hey tom our friends at manscaped have
just launched their fourth generation
performance package and that includes
the lawnmower
four you heard that right john the four
oh the lawnmower four i'm using that
quite a lot right now because summer's
coming and the lawnmower four
has a little light attachment so for
those hard to reach
areas it actually shines a little light
so you can get as close as you want
and the package four doesn't just have
the lawnmower
it has the weed whacker ear and nose
hair trimmer crop preserver ball
deodorant
crop reviver toner performance boxer
briefs and a travel bag to hold all the
goodies
that is a lot and you have to keep an
eye on your nose and ear hairs because
that is not an attractive look guys
you and i make sure that if we've got
any hairs coming out of those areas we
tell each other don't we yeah the weed
whacker will get rid of all of those
absolutely it will so get 20 off plus
free shipping with the code
onionmanscape.com that's 20
off plus free shipping with the code
onion manscaped.com
escape the shrubs and weeds this summer
and shine with manscaped
can anyone out of the three of us
name the author of the book
jaws people at home are screaming this
out right now
i did not i did not even know it was a
book
book bills it's a brilliant book
i'm not alone i don't i i thought it
came from the mind of the filmmaker no
it's a
brilliant book although i wouldn't
advise you to read it when you're on a
beach getting ready to jump into the
ocean but it isn't you'd love i'm buying
you that book i'm buying you that book
and it was written by that's unusual for
you to put your hand in your pocket
so i love it you must love that book it
was written by
i believe peter either bleachly
or bleachly i don't know how you say the
last name
a brilliant book well if we're all part
of this um
conversation just now i also think you
should buy it for mariah
mariah consider it done we'll get your
address i'll send you a copy of
jaws signed by billy boyd
and dominic mohan and possibly a shark
if we can get hold of it definitely get
the shark
yeah we went off in a tangent we've got
a habit of doing that sorry mariah
um do you have any other questions or is
okay um
well i see you're leafing through notes
you're so fully immersed in the tolkien
universe in lord of the rings like was
it as magical
as i like always imagined it that's
it's really nice question actually
mariah and this makes me think of
something that ian mckellen said to
to us after we'd made the movies
and i think the first one was out and he
said
it's it's funny talking to people
about the movies because they want to
talk about the movies but really he said
what he feels as people wanted
to be in middle earth he felt when he's
talking to people they
they want to feel like the actors felt
like they were in middle earth
because the people watching the movies
want to feel that
and you know what sometimes it did feel
like that
especially the more remote um places
that we went to topper mountains or you
know
going down rivers or whatever and we
were all in costume
and having packed lunches and there was
times when it absolutely felt like
we were in tolkien's um universe and not
this one you know
and do you remember like you and i and
and a bunch of other cast members but
you and i quite a lot would take that
kind of
rickety country road
to like edouras or to some of those
places
with with boromir and the closer and
closer you got the further away from
civilization also moria i remember
all of the fellowship walking into moria
and pete jackson being very giggly and
excitable that day because it was the
first time we got a chance to see the
set
and he was going look look at that
skeleton look at that dead skull and
look at that dead goblin look at that
axe in the wall look at those spears
and he was really really excited about
the set and we were all nudging each
other just saying can you believe how
amazing this is yeah
and then they brought out the cave troll
which was basically just a tennis ball
on a pole
and that was disappointing that was
disappointing we thought the cave troll
would have looked better than that
and what was the ball was the balrog
anything
we wouldn't running away from nothing
there was you know
yeah a mark on a wall so there we go but
great question mariah
thank you very much can we ask you a
question
what are what are you doing with your
time these days are you working
are you a student oh i'm working
yes um i work at currently at a
non-profit organization
in downtown atlanta but i'm also working
on becoming
an english as a second language teacher
ah
does your brother do that my brother
teaches
science to spanish kids
in english so they're they're an
english immersion school all these
spanish kids where they learn all their
lessons in english
so they're also in there just to make it
more difficult they're learning english
as a side hustle so you're learning
english
accidentally through science right and
my brother
matthew hello matt hiya matt um
well mariah is lovely speaking to you
what's on your t-shirt is that the
mandalorian no
it's um oh it's us i
i thought the top of elijah's head was a
mandalorian helmet i've always thought
that
that's how medicated i am right now
hey mariah take care of yourself look
out for that book we will send you a
copy of jaws
in the mail lovely to meet you mariah
bye-bye
bye bye-bye oh emails and real mails
fastest tigers slow as snails bills were
back
yes here we are and we've got questions
on voicemail
should we listen why wouldn't we okay
hi lads cameron here from ireland i just
want to say congratulations on the new
podcast it's filling my weeks with joy
as the lord of the rings movies have
filled my life with joy over the past 20
years
i just want to ask billy i know you grew
up in glasgow dom you grew up in
stockport
but are now both living in l.a what do
you miss
most about your hometowns and why
i would say i mean i miss a lot of stuff
but i think i miss
l.a is like really big and spread out
and everybody's in their cars all the
time
and i like just walking you know me
meeting a friend for a pint just saying
yeah
i'll meet you in the local problem we'll
go for a pint
and also a thing that people do in l.a
which i've i've always thought is weird
is if someone's going for
a vodka cocktail or
or a pudding a rice pudding they have to
go
to the greatest vodka cocktail bar
or the greatest rice pudding i want to
go to the closest one
yeah i don't want to you're i've been
with you
and for dinner and then one of our
friends would say
oh there's a new custard place we should
all go there for our
we did it once actually we were up near
your place and uh
and somebody we were with said oh let's
go for pudding now let's go for a
and i was like no let's have pudding in
the restaurant we're in no
dessert sorry no it's fine we say
pudding we say pudding dessert
and he wanted to get out we all get into
cars and we all drive to another place
to get
the pudding to get the dessert weird i
don't want to do that no
i wanted an out if it's a cocktail
i don't want to go to a place downtown
you know that serves the greatest
cocktail i'll just go to the place right
there i totally hear you on that one and
also one of the
underestimated great joys of life
for me is walking after dinner oh yeah
i love that feeling of paying the bill
and then going for like a
half hour 45 minute walk home and yeah
it sounds kind of a bit medical but your
whole digestive system is like oh thanks
we can start to get things moving a
little easier and you just feel like and
by the time you get home you're ready
for a poo
and that's you ready for bed and then
you're done yeah fantastic
successful day my answer is kind of
similar to yours
bills i i mean obviously it's a little
cliche
to say that you miss your friends and
family but that's that's you know one of
one of the top ones
but like billy had said football day
you know a game will kick off at three
you just know right we're gonna go to
this pub you walk in you're not sure who
you're gonna expect there but everyone's
there
few beers maybe you walk somewhere else
to get a
chinese or or get an indian there is the
pub
culture in britain is so strong and so
enmeshed
in things like sport and the back pages
of the newspaper or maybe you're sitting
around talking about the news
so i do miss the community aspect but in
a way
we've kind of commandeered it ourselves
haven't we because of
hanging out sitting in your garden
chatting yeah that is a little
mini public a little bit and we did have
a couple of beers on saturday night only
three
only three that was plenty done
lovely question there from the emerald
isle
hi dom and billy i'm loving the podcast
so far and i'm so glad you guys are
doing this
my question is for billy um how was your
experience
voice acting in the seat of chucky did
you get to interact with brad doroth
who was also in the lord of the rings um
more in that film than you did in
the lord of the rings thank you so much
before you answer bills yeah it is
wonderful to have a question
put forward by a chipmunk isn't it it's
a lovely voice
it reminded me of that actress who's now
doing the new show
[Music]
he's not going to remember this is right
here we go down this road he
is so terrible at actors names so
she's a brilliant actress meryl streep
quite small
she's acting with a an actor who's very
tall
who used to be the bar man in cheers
oh ted danson you're thinking of kristen
bell no
no he's a like a counselor honestly guys
this is
every time i see billy's like have you
seen that show with the
with the girl who's a thing she used to
be a car
now she's a lollipop but this is a great
actress
and she sounded like that how old what
does she look like
i would say i don't want to tell her
late 40s small
is she of indian descent no she's
american
through and through late late 40s
small and she's in the new ted danson
and then she is brilliant and she sounds
like that girl
and while john's finding that i'll talk
about cedar chucky
yeah yeah for god's sake because um brad
duroff of course
is a wonderful actor now is he the
original chuckie he is chucky
and all the chucky movies no idea yeah
until they made the new
i think they've rebooted it and it's
mark hamill
right i got a name brilliant oh well
done thank you
and uh but they're going to make a tv
show now
and it will be brad duraf who's chucky
and
i love brad dura from um one flew over
the cuckoo's nest
and i think he was oscar-nominated was
he really not
i thought that was devito was nominated
but well jack nixon won didn't he
i should hope so yeah but brad duraff i
always thought was a brilliant
really so when i heard he was coming in
to do worm tongue
i was very excited and we didn't get a
lot to do with them no we don't do that
even when he was in eisenguard it was a
pretend eisen guard for us because he
was supposed to be at the top of the
tower
remember so we didn't have a lot to do
with them
and sadly when i did seed of chucky
i was in uh i think i was in the uk
recording that so i'd again i didn't get
to work with brad
right but they had a lot of um i was
acting with his voice because they'd
already
recorded a lot of the stuff and uh i had
a lot of fun doing that movie
because the director wanted it to be
um sort of the keynesian sort of you
know
oliver you know and then these two
different
um parts to the character and obviously
the sort of
he's not sure what sex he is and uh and
i like that part of it that
they were exploring the sort so you play
chucky's kid
yes who is uh he doesn't know if he's a
boy or a girl
right um non-binary non-binary and
they wanted that to be part and i'm i'm
very proud of that part of it
you know that they brought that story
into it so um it was great fun to do it
and uh the actress that you sound like
is john howie hunter
holy hunter holly hunter she's fantastic
i would have explained holly hunter
better for you dom well i would have
said the uh
the lady who played the lead in the
piano oh that would have been a good one
oh she's also in the uh hateful eight
and she's brilliant in the hatefully oh
that would have been another good one
she's fantastic she is like a powerhouse
isn't she
yeah uh very quickly on brad duraff
his english accent in lord rings is
perfect
absolutely textbook and i love some of
the choices that he made remember he
he had like a very delicate little silk
handkerchief and he used to like
mop the side of his mouth with it which
is kind of disgusting but brilliant for
women
yeah he used to come in all precious and
be sire
i think you should do this yeah all
these choices
religiously great actor great question
yes
shall i read this one out um luke no
you're billy not me
how did that become luke luke sorry
luke has an interesting question here
well actually it's a riddle you know
what
i know the answer to this question so
maybe i should read it to you read it to
me and i'll see if i know here's a
riddle for you i'll keep my eyes closed
so it's the first time i've heard that
nice
there's a little a la golem two men are
found at the bottom of a tall cliff
each are wearing a backpack one of them
lies on the ground dead with a closed
pack
the other stands alive with an open pack
what is inside
the backpack says luke l
two men bottom of the cliff both got
backpacks one's open he's alive
one's closed it's shut i've got it
can i ask you a very honest question
yeah have you heard this before
no oh go on what i don't think you have
heard it but i do know the answer i
think oh god
a parachute i think that's the answer
isn't it yeah
10 points for me
thank you very much guys if you guys do
have a riddle or a conundrum
that's a good thing i love riddles and
bills does too so send us your riddles
send us your conundrums
no that i think that'll become a good
thing that'd be great right yeah
definitely send those
where would this end at dom well you can
email us
the friendship onion at castmedia.com
that's cast with a k
or you can send us a voicemail www
dot you don't need the www or you can
send us a voicemail
speak pipe forward slash
i've ruined it i can never remember the
speak pipe part
and you always forget the dot com so
i'll do the first bit right or you can
send us a voicemail at speakpipe.com
forward slash the friendship onion we've
done it what a team
okay now i'm gonna scroll down a little
bit because let's see if there's any
more
questions here that might be the only oh
no there's more questions right
here i'll give you this one someone has
a buttery question we love buttery
questions
gary t everyone's always
is just a letter for the second name
they want to be anonymous is that what
you do yes we incriminate them ah good
gary t is from cornwall uk do you
remember we went to cornwall once
yeah we went surfing there didn't we it
was fun wasn't it yeah i remember
jumping off a cliff
to get into the surf do you remember
that yeah it wasn't that when i say a
cliff
yeah a rock a rock we're just very small
i've given thought to an interesting
butter question and it made me think
about
the butter toast phenomenon supposedly
if you drop a buttered slice of toast it
will
always land butter side down in addition
to this
cats have the ability to self-right when
falling
so when a cat falls it will always land
on its feet
now combine these two dom
and you're presented with the buttered
cat
paradox if you drop a buttered cat from
a height
would it land on its feet would itself
right
or would it be a combination of the two
causing the cat to endlessly spin
around hovering slightly above the
ground
it's a fantastic question it's a
fantastic question it's a little um
hypothetical i do have a very boring
i would think correct answer to this do
you have any thoughts
i well i i like this because i feel as
if i'm at a university just now yeah
studying something incredible like
philosophy
and string theory yeah and and and i
feel like
i would like to discuss this well let's
discuss right
my thoughts are this this is more of a
conclusion than a discussion
cats have free will don't they cats well
do they
well cats cat
cats always want to survive like most
living things they think well given the
choice of
death or life i'm gonna go for life
right but butter doesn't right as far as
we know yeah
you know once you get do if you get down
into the string theory bottom maybe it
does want to survive yeah
so if you spread butter on a cat on its
back
on its back there is an overwhelming
advantage
to the cat's need to survive
since the butter itself does not is that
a very logical boring way of answering
no i don't think that's boring at all
i think that's absolutely brilliant but
imagine a a world if you will
where butter will always land that way
down
so you're saying it's will to survive
we'll always get it to its feet
but we're living in a universe where
butter will always land
is there ever ever a world where the cat
will spin
above the ground i mean they're
definitely in it in a quantum world
all of those things are happening right
there's spinning cats all over the place
you can you can walk down the road
without hitting one remember trying to
explain or not explain but try and
kind of open up the conversation to my
mate tom
about the idea that you know that
concept of if you gave
an infinite amount of apes a typewriter
sooner or later they will write the
complete works of shakespeare yeah some
said absolutely well and i said yeah if
you give them an infinite amount of time
add an infinite amount of apes they will
and tom said no they will
and this went on and on and i was like
but it's the word infinite that is
important here tom
and he said no they won't
so you know but it's a great question
gary t
hang on we have another one here and we
will never say no they won't because we
like to discuss these things
please send us your bigger more
expansive questions we
absolutely look look we love answering
questions about lord rings as well but
we love these bigger ones
billy and dom eat the world uh
fantastic subjective you guys keep them
coming
and now do you know what time it is
bills i hope it's my favorite time of
the day
it's time for billy and dummy the world
and this is the best time to have the
eat the world thing
because i'm absolutely starving i'm a
little peckish too here comes john here
comes jonathan
wonderful glory what have we got here
yes today we're doing salty
licorice from scandinavia or salziji
salty herrings they would be and i think
this cactus uh
company is quite a famous salty
licorice company now here's a good way
to kick it off
yeah because this is one of the first
things that i notice about you in new
zealand the way that
either you or scottish people say the
word licorice is completely different to
the way
english people say and yours seems more
accurate than the way that we say
because you say licorice and we say
shake we say licorice
but there's not an sh at the end of it
there is a ce
but i think probably the most famous
scotsman in the world
sean sean connery would say licorice
but most people would say licorice
wait most scots would say licorice yes
licorice
i think john do you want to just give us
a little licorice or licorice
i'm a licorice licorice with an sh at
the end even though it doesn't have one
i guess so i don't know my dad love
black licorice and tell me something
else
because that says herring there's
another fish
i'm not going to say it the way i see it
often using two in him
often using tuna fish sandwiches
[Laughter]
how would you see that fish oh a big
fish that is wonderful but not not
described oh what
i would say because yeah there's a
massive difference between america and
english right i would say
tuna but over here tuna
and scotland tuna tuna
like a guitar tuner wait um so tuna
tuna tuna yeah that's a lot
there's a lot going on there boys i
don't hear much of the difference of dom
but you're right hold on
you say tuna tuna i say
tuna yeah almost like a t-e-w
and can i say main again tuna yeah
tuna tuna by the way the fish one of
the largest most aggressive most
important
fish in the ocean and a spectacular fish
what makes a fish important well in
terms of
they are a keystone species
in the ocean they eat a lot of smaller
fish
they are food for a lot of sharks
there's massive
shoals of them that move around the
planet and that dictates how a lot of
other fish and aquatic animals
move around the planet so they're like
influencers they're big influences
a lot of followers on aquatic social
media and
uh a large blue fin tuner
can be upwards of half a million dollars
yeah
well you remember this dom we were in
mexico once right
uh visiting orlando bloom on the cast of
a movie
right and we went to a sushi restaurant
and the next day the guy said we're
going out fishing
and we went if you remember and i caught
a 60-pound
tuna yeah and the guy
took it and he never gave me any money
and he sold that in his restaurant
probably for two days and made himself
probably
over a million dollars he might have and
we we
specifically said when we went out on
that boat we will catch fish
but we want to throw them back in and he
went yeah yeah that's fine
but then when we caught a massive tuna
he went well we'll just put that in the
ice cream and i think he charged us to
be on the boat
when you say oz you mean the three of us
whereas
orlando was down there literally making
millions of dollars
and he was like yeah uh yeah boys we'll
split it right we barely got any
talking about boats dom what's the
difference between a boat and a ship
i want to say something to do with
sighs not bad
a ship
that's an interesting could i have a
clue no oh yeah of course
i bought is smaller right so it is size
i've done it but it's not quite that but
when does a boat become a ship
ship has something on it
that a boat does not a boat is smaller
a ship there is something on a ship
always on a ship but it is never on a
boat
a ship has a crow's nest
no a ship has a dual
engine no is it something to do the way
that it moves
it's something to do with the boat a
ship always has
a captain
a ship always has
a boat on it oh that is brilliant
yeah i know is that right that's how you
define a ship a ship has a boat on it
and a boat does not have this bug's way
too small to have a ship on it yeah
so titanic was a ship yes
and the little vessel that they go out
in jaws on is a boat a boat
that's a brilliant piece of trivia that
i did thank you very much anyway this is
billy dominate the world this
show's gone on forever yeah come on we
are doing salty licorice
salty licorice now i'm very excited
about this because i spent some time
in sweden did you in stockholm in uh
vasasthan
i lived on ready for this yep ross
transcotton
oh that's very good yeah which is one of
the more exclusive uh
streets of uh stockholm and the salty
licorice there
was fantastic i'm taking three i'm
passing it over to it
i'm hoping that this this is going to be
mickey braw
oh mickey brown very good thank you what
that means in sweden
so let's read a few facts about uh
liquid well first of all just from a
personal point of view
because i know this because i've spent
some time with you you're a big fan of
licorice aren't you i love licorice
yeah it's probably my favorite would you
call it a sweet a candy yeah i think
it's whatever it is i love it
although the the initial origins
of licorice is it's is it a part of a
a tuber or a or a super
tuba well not the not the the musical
instrument
no t-u-b-o-r thing because when i was a
kid
my parents uh used to give me a
stick yeah and the stick did you have
that from you folks
the stick had a very very licoricy
taste to it and i think that's where it
comes from is that a root i think it's a
a tuber or a root or a branch if you
could get in touch with anyone out there
but yeah right can i eat well yeah i'm
going to give it a little
sniff smell test do you know what oh it
smells great
my mouth is going weird at the thought
of this have you had this before
yeah something like it i think and my
mouth is already going weird
in the same way as my dog little bobby
johnson
will sometimes follow a beetle
or a fly around the floor and then i can
see the moment where he imagines it
being in his mouth
and he goes
it flies drive him deaf don't they you
said that flies actually give him a
little bit of anxiety yeah he goes crazy
goes under the bed
there's a shop in uh los angeles called
soccer bit which means sugar cube and
you can get
all of your sour or salty licorice from
there my mouth's going funny can we do
it let's give it a go
there we go
chewy hmm
yeah are you salivating
it's really really good it's
it's not as intense as i expected
i think to be honest there is saltier
licorice out there i'm having a second
one there we go
mastication is extremely important
especially with like chris i'm getting a
bit
trapped between the back of my tooth
it's very good licorice
it's not as salty as i had expected
salmiak the ones that i get from
soccer bit sometimes you have to roll
around your mouth
in a few different places so as not to
cause aggravation on the tip of your
tongue or the side of your mouth and it
feels like you're not you can't quite
bite it because you're like oh me i'm
not quite ready for this
have you ever had one of those kind of
canker
sores on the inside of your mouth and
then if you have like salt and vinegar
crisps or something like this
oh that's painful but that tell me
something about this job
all right well let's have a little read
of it i'm going to scroll down
salty licorice or salmiak
licorice is a variety of licorice
flavored with the ingredient
salmiak salt which includes
sal al-monyak and al-amin
not aluminium aluminium oh yeah it's
ammonium ammonium chloride and it's a
common
confection found in nordic countries and
northern germany
in fact there is a tiny little
kind of box similar to a box of tic tacs
in germany of salty licorice very salty
licorice that you can get
which is called spunk
don't say i'm good i'll just eat your
licorice
any any other facts that you've got go
down a little bit because i really i'm
interested in this ammonium chloride
which is water see ammonium chloride
and licorice was first combined to
produce this salty licorice
they're not sure when but by the 1930s
it was produced in finland norway
denmark sweden and the netherlands
as a pastilla i think pastels have
some element of medicinal quality to
them
i mean if you've got a sore throat you
suck a pastel or if you've got some
issue and isn't
licorice in its more raw form associated
with
aiding a lethargic digestive system
really i think so can you pass the bag
over and stop being so such a greedy
guts
so it's the ammonium chloride the
salmiak
salt that gives it that flavor um
and it varies by country what is
considered a safe amount
in sweden for example the most popular
types
contain an average of seven percent of
this ammonium chloride
but in 2012 there was a european
union proposal to limit the amount
to zero point three percent wow that is
a tiny
so in sweden there was seven percent of
this ammonium chloride
that the eu what i nearly choked out
them
wanted to limit it to 0.3 so is ammonium
chloride bad for you
well it seems like it might be if
they're trying to limit it there's
something about it and
tell me if i'm i'm on the wrong road
here
that reminds me a cap piss
is that something that you've often
drank no
but there's something that is there
something about ammonium
oh ammonia ammonia so like if i passed
somewhere where a cat peed
i'm kind of getting a bit of that from
this
but not in a bad way or when you step
into a
a men's toilet that has not been given
a uh recent cleaning and you get hit
with that
is that ammonia pissy smell so there's
something about
ammonium chloride or salmiak
salt that is is in cappy
which i said the tang of south salmiak
is so popular in the regions
of scandinavia it's used to flavor
pastries
tobacco packets wow and even
meat dishes well tom i have to say it's
one of my
favorite flavors so i say keep it up
there at seven percent
yeah i know you love it because europe
is would it be fair to say that your
favorite american confection
is good and plenty yeah but the
the the box is too big and i can't stop
eating it
yeah so i eat the whole box and then i
feel bad about myself don't feel bad
but it makes me feel a bit sick go about
up again there was something
else that was up again but um yeah i
love licorice
and my favorite type of licorice is this
salty
i didn't know it was um i didn't know it
was
uh what was it ammonium chloride i
didn't know that's what gave it this
but that is delicious says it says hey
that ammonium chloride has a history of
being used as a cough medicine
oh yeah as it works as an expectorant
now my mum who's listening
hello maureen hello uh would know
exactly what expectorant is but i get
the feeling that expectorant might be
it it uh allows the phlegm to
possibly come up a little easier i would
say it would loosen it maybe
break it down a little easier hmm well
done
hey wait let me finish this oh yeah okay
finnish
author yuka anala
speculates that salty licorice has its
origin in pharmacy stores that
manufactured their own cough medicine
people got used to like the taste and
then they were like well we'll take the
medicine out and we'll just create the
sweet
i get that yeah i get the i get the
cough medicine thing as well
i love it how do you feel about
red licorice because for me i don't
think that stuff should be called
licorice it's red
sweeties it's not licorice no it's a
different thing isn't it i like
i like the texture of it in my back
teeth
red vines can't do that all right tastes
like chemicals to me
no i quite like a red vein but not as
much as a salty licorice i'm gonna take
one more so that we can give them scores
come on get this score some the doors
there you go right so taste right
i have to admit john and again john
you're slightly in the doghouse
although anyone out there that's
listening or watching the podcast this
is all in jest
john is never really in the dog house
we're just having fun sometimes yes
actually sometimes i think
we could have gone a little bit more
hardcore we could have
said to the people in the shop give us
your saltiest give us your most hard
cooks i don't think this is it
still tasty it's incredibly tasty
um i get the hardcore thing the
aftertaste has the hardcore
um i want it in the curing taste i
wonder what my breath smells like after
this
you won't be able to tell me because
you've eaten it true but after a morning
of coffee and black licorice
your wife's in for a treat i wouldn't
let i wouldn't mind
letting john have a smell of my breath
after this let's do it well
in terms of taste or flavor same thing
i'm gonna dock a few points because it
wasn't quite as extreme as i wanted but
it's still strong because i like it
i'm gonna give it a solid 7.9
i think that's a good mark and i'm going
to give it uh an
eight always next
aesthetics the look now are we talking
about in the packet are we talking about
both it's charming it's a herring it's a
is this a little fish it's a tiny little
thing
are they trying to win on the back of
swedish fish
well probably i mean i think cactus
might be a swedish company
it seems like it swedish fish salty
herring
yeah that's how i remember it yeah i
think that's true i like it it's
charming
um who doesn't like fish
crabs maybe i think there's a turf war
between crabs and fish to be fair well
i've learned a lot about tunas today
yeah everybody likes tunas yeah they're
they're a keystone species
in terms of the aesthetic of the bag
which looks like a little sea breeze
doesn't it
and the fish i'm to give the aesthetics
a 9.4 i'll get that a 7.8 oh you want
that
i don't see why it's a fish and can be a
fish it should be a spiral or something
it should be its own shape okay i'm fine
i'm going to dock it more 7.2
oh you've been quite cool and then
usefulness
i mean stick it in your garden eat it
but apart from that apart from that i
mean what
i mean put it in like a 10p mixture
so it's portable you could take it on a
plane on a trip
but you you couldn't make a stew from it
no you couldn't
you're not going to see someone put that
in a sandwich no
could you make ice cream black licorice
ice cream not brilliant really
could you take it to a pub with your
mates they're eating crisps and nuts
you're like here have a
pairing no have a salty herring
usefulness i'm sorry about this cactus
i'm giving it a a 0.7
that's mean hang on here comes john
what about as an expectorant though
can it still be used medicinally
i think in terms of an expectorant there
seems to be a lot looser phlegm in your
mouth currently than there was
it seems to be getting some movement now
yeah so maybe bump it up a little i'll
give it a one i'll give it a one i don't
think it's
medicinal but it is vegan so any vegans
out there wanting to have a little
sweetie
and also like if you if you thought you
know i'd like my breath to smell
like awful like a salty licorice then
that was what you would eat i'll give it
a three
lovely stuff guys send in your
suggestions
for billy and domi the world to us
at the friendship onion at castmedia.com
or speak
pipe dot com forward slash the
friendship onion
or you can also obviously just leave
comments or
uh you know concerns or questions
underneath where you get your podcast or
on our youtube channel the friendship on
you
don't forget to subscribe rate and
reviewers
and if we find a review that we really
like there's a chance we might put it up
on our social media pages
yeah so don't forget to tag us in your
reviews take a picture send it to us
we'll put it on instagram or we'll read
them out here
and we'll see you next week see you next
week
hey guys we're back just one more thing
tonight we will be on the late show
with stephen colbert yeah let us know
what you think let us know what you
think of our appearance
let us know if you could answer the
devilishly hard lord of the rings
questions that we asked
stephen colbert and let us know what you
think of billy's fantastic outfit so
please
tune in and watch the late show tonight
with stephen colbert
and me and dominic monahan see ya